the whole purpose of being on this
planet is to learn more about each other
and to learn more about the place where
we are we are curious by nature I'm
Erica Bergman I'm a submarine pilot and
a National Geographic Explorer being a
submarine pilot is my absolute dream job
it is unusual down there is such an
awe-inspiring way the ocean is 75% of
the planet the majority of life on Earth
is in the ocean when National Geographic
and Coors Light approached me about my
next they said what's on your pocket I
went bold I was like I want to go to
space they said we can't do that I said
I still want to go
I want to see the world from the
opposite direction I wanted to come to
the jungle I wanted to climb into the
canopy Costa Rica has ten different
climate zones everything from tropical
rainforests to coastal ecosystems
curiosity keeps me excited about life
look inside yourself and find that
thirst for more
find your next adventure
[Music]